it's pretty dope like like the last few
years i've just noticed how
atlanta is fully behind you like you are
like they take pride in you they show up
they see me grow up though yeah and so
you know we always hear about like i
feel like
90 percent of
well first of all culture hip-hop music
all of this has been in atlanta's for
the last 20 years oh yeah for sure since
like 2000 it's been a very long time you
guys have had the
the reigns
but um
we always hear about like how important
it is if you're coming out of atlanta
to and it's very heavily saturated
market with artists
because a lot of people move there too
to try to make it in the rap game what
were the things you had to make sure you
did to pop off in your own city before
you had it before we got big energy
because i know it's a very it's it's a
it's a very tough place to i mean as
much as people are like it's easy
everyone in atlanta is popping no no
it's a lot of competition it's
oversaturated because everybody that
live here want to rap and then you got
people who come here to pursue their
rapping dreams or singing dreams or
whatever but i think i really had the
easy way out because i've been doing it
so long like it wasn't no thought
process into this [ __ ] like oh like i'm
an adult now what i'm going to do like
i want to do like i it's all i know like
i've been doing like real when i say
rapping that hey i'm not talking about
like for my momma and [ __ ] i'm talking
about like i would get picked up from
school do my homework in the studio
lobby and then go record type [ __ ] like
full-blown open mics talent shows like
my daddy had me doing everything in
atlanta and that's why like
every artist in london seen me somewhere
like i didn't did a show opened up for
something with every artist in atlanta
so that's why i get so much love and
respect because they like because
they've seen you grow up yeah this ain't
no microwave no overnight like [ __ ] yeah
she put in her [ __ ] work for this
[ __ ] so they respect it do you um
because we always think of like
when you're coming up as an artist right
you have opportunities to open up for
artists sometimes you got to pay to open
up did you ever have to do that
my daddy for sure didn't pay like 200
here 300 here to like just that just to
get yourself